welcome back with the summer heating up
Intermountain Health the sponsors of
this next segment are reminding nevadans
about the importance of staying safe
when exploring the Great Outdoors here
to tell us more is Dr Albert Shu with
Intermountain Health welcome to the show
thank you for having me it's great
having you here so this is a serious
stat trauma is the leading cause of
death in people under 46. that's correct
but there are ways to prevent that and
that's where to break down today
absolutely and the first thing is
something very simple is wearing your
seatbelt yes yes it's very important it
takes a few seconds but then the
importance of fluency bills shows in
statistics so according to the Nevada
state statistics about 20 percent of the
fatality related to unrestrained drivers
on the road is due to you know not
winning seat belt and then nationally
it's over 50 percent of the fatality on
the roads are due to people not wearing
seat belts that's a heavy number to
digest if we just buckled up everyone
buckled up 50 of the lives across the
country would be saved absolutely okay
so this is something that gets me is
wearing a helmet on a motorcycle or
moving object right that's right because
um
even something as you know simple as
like a bike or a scooter the trauma that
can can cause it can be tremendous so
wearing a helmet really helps now
there's statistic that shows that if you
wear a helmet it can reduce the head
related trauma by 68 and then death
about 40 these numbers are staggering
but it's also it's not just dirt bikes
and mopeds and stuff you see people on
these electric scooters yes they think
it's a scooter you're gonna be fine but
you're going 30 miles per hour you fall
into concrete without a helmet you're
back in a bad spot absolutely yes so
it's very important to wear a helmet
somebody we've got Lake Mead life vest
how important are life vests oh life has
is also very important especially living
in southern Nevada where it's really
hard people like to go to the lake go to
the rivers and to engage all sorts of
water related Sports it's very important
to wear a light vest especially when
you're out there if you you drown it's
hard to get EMS to go to rescue you so
do yourself a favor and your family
favorite with a life less and if you're
supposed to be doing water with sports
out there and they're like it's so much
fun being pull behind an inner tube or
something you get tossed off that thing
you fall in the water you turned around
for a second you got the light vest it
brings you right back up and things are
safe absolutely the heat Ted was talking
about these crazy temperatures that are
coming how important is it to stay
hydrated oh it's extremely important
both for children and adults now for
adults on average an adult male should
consume about 15 to 16 cups of water a
day okay adult female about 11 to 12
cups now of course that number goes up
because you know you can lose a lot of
the fluid incense bleach through the
sweat so it's very important to stay
hydrated and the old saying is still
true if you're thirsty you're already
dehydrated it's past the point of no
reason well it's not past the point of
return but it's the point where you need
to start drinking some water absolutely
you're already dehydrated yes people are
traveling maybe they're going overseas
to a foreign country vaccinations how
important oh very important now depends
on where you go usually in the Stateside
you're safe but if you go
internationally for example like the
yellow fever virus which is pandemic in
part of South America and Africa so if
you're going to those locations make
sure you get the vaccines beforehand
according to the CDC guidelines protect
yourself absolutely I love it doctor
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it and thank you to
Intermountain Health for sponsoring this
segment for more information visit
intermountainhealthnv.org Jillian